[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the ones of the wizarding
world
now if you're a fan of the wizarding
world then you'll know that witches and
wizards
hold one particular instrument very true
to their hearts
the wand a wand is the object through
which a witch or wizard
channels his or her magic it is made
from wood
and has a magical substance at its core
ones made by olivander are of varying
woods
lengths and flexibilities as shown above
ones come in a variety of shapes colours
sizes
flexibilities and materials the main
parameters that differentiate
each one are as follows length core type
and lastly wood type which is the focus
of this video
length generally pertains to the size
and or character of the witch
wizard and similar to the length of the
wand the type of wood and core
are also generally considered to be
extensions of the witch or wizard's
personality
one thing worth mentioning however is
that the one component with the highest
variability
is the wand wood of which there are 38
different types
ollivander discusses which trees can
produce wood for ones
here only a minority of trees can
produce one quality
wood just as a minority of humans can
produce magic
it takes years of experience to tell
which ones have the gift
although the job is made easier if
bowtruckles are found
nesting in the leaves as they never
inhabit mundane trees
we know that harry is ultimately given
an 11 inch wand made of holly
and we know that tom riddle had a 13 and
a half inch wand made a view
we even know the one to wood materials
of many other characters
but in today's video i want to discuss
every wonder wood in existence
that is every wood material that could
potentially be used to make a wand
a lot of information pertaining to ones
is best described by olivander himself
so i'm going to be using his own
explanations
there are a lot to get through so let's
get started
acacia acacia is a large genus of shrubs
and trees
that belongs to the subfamily memo
saudia
of the family for basie first described
in africa
apparently this type of one word is
particularly hard to match with a witch
or wizard
ollivander had this to say a very
unusual wand wood which i found creates
tricky ones that often refuse to produce
magic
for any but their owner and also
withhold their best effects
from all but those most gifted this
sensitivity
renders them difficult to place they
keep only a small stock
for those witches or wizards of
sufficient subtlety
for acacia is not suited to what is
commonly known
as bang and smells magic the only known
wizard to have potentially had this
material in his wand
is jacob's sibling from the hogwarts
mystery game
alder ulda is the common name of a
genius of flowering plants
allness belonging to the birch family
bettu lacie
the genus ulness comprises about 30
species of different trees and shrubs
that are commonly found near streams
rivers and wetlands
ollivander had this to say older is an
unyielding wood
yet i have discovered that its ideal
owner is not stubborn or obstinate
but often helpful considerate and to
most likeable
whereas most one words seek similarity
in the characters of those that they
will best serve
alder is unusual in that it seems to
desire a nature that is
if not precisely opposite to its own
then certainly of a markedly different
type
he also added that it is best suited to
non-verbal
spell work kurana squirrel notably used
an older wand that was nine
inches in length apple i'm sure you've
heard of apple trees before
which come from the species malus
domestica in the rose family
olivendar had this to say applewood ones
are not made in great numbers
they are powerful and best suited to an
owner of high aims and ideals
as this wood mixes poorly with dark
magic it is said that the possessor of
an apple wand will be well loved and
long-lived
but i've often noticed that customers of
great personal charm
find their perfect match in an applewood
wand one other interesting aspect of
applewood one donors is that they can
commonly converse with other magical
beings
in their native tongues on that note a
wizard by the name of dylan marwood
who authored merpeople a comprehensive
guide to their language and customs
was known to have used an apple wood
wand ash
the ash tree is a type of tree belonging
to the genus
fraxinus containing flowering plants in
the olive and
lilac family olivander had this to say
the ash wand cleaves to its one true
master and ought not to be passed on
or gifted from the original owner
because it will lose power and skill
this tendency is extreme if the core is
of unicorn
old superstitions regarding ones rarely
bear close examination
but i find that the old rhyme regarding
rowan chestnut ash and hazel ones
rowan gossips chestnut drones ash's
stubborn hazel moans
contains a small nugget of truth he also
added that the ideal owner may be
stubborn
and will certainly be courageous but
never crass or arrogant
on the vein of or not to be passed on or
gifted this is actually the wand that
was passed down from charlie weasley
to ron weasley hence why ron had so many
difficulties with his first wand
aspen aspen is a common name for certain
tree species
some of which are classified by the
genus populous
these types of trees are endemic to the
northern hemisphere
ollivander had this to say one quality
aspenwood is white and fine grained
and is highly prized by all want makers
for its stylish resemblance to ivory
and its usually outstanding charm work
the proper owner of the aspen wand is
often an accomplished duelist
or destined to be so for the aspen wand
is one of those particularly suited
to martial magic bearing that in mind
there are no known owners of an aspen
wand
according to canon other than members of
an infamous and secretive 18th century
dueling club called the silver spears
which would only admit those who used an
aspen wand
beech beech is the common name for a
genus of 10 species
of deciduous trees in the family for jca
these types of trees are endemic to
great britain ollivander had this to say
the true match for a beach wand will be
if young
lies beyond his or her years and if
full-grown
rich in understanding and experience
beach ones perform very weakly for the
narrow-minded and
intolerant and such wizards and witches
having obtained a beach wand without
having been suitably matched
yet coveting this most desirable richly
hewed and highly prized wand wood
have often presented themselves at the
homes of learned wand makers such as
myself
demanding to know the reason for the
handsome ones lack of power
when properly matched the beach wand is
capable of a subtlety and artistry
rarely seen in any other wand hence its
lustrous
reputation i wasn't able to find any
information on witches or wizards
that use a beach wand blackthorne
blackthorne aka prunus spinosa
is a species of flowering plant in the
rose family
rosaceae it is native to europe western
asia
and locally in northwest africa
ollivander had this to say
blackthorne which is a very unusual one
would has the reputation
in my view well merited of best being
suited
to the warrior this does not necessarily
mean that its owner practices the dark
arts
although it is undeniable that those who
do so will enjoy the blackthorne ones
prodigious power one finds blackthorne
ones among the auras as well as among
the denisons of azkaban
as far as witches wizards that use
blackthorne ones
only two are known the first is
circadogen
a wizard and swore knight of the round
table and the second was an unnamed
snatcher
black walnut black walnut is a specific
type of walnut that is native to eastern
north america
growing mainly in wetlands olivander had
this to say
less common than the standard walnut
wand that of black walnut seeks a master
of good instincts and powerful insight
black walnut is a very handsome wood but
not the easiest to master
it has one pronounced quirk which is
that it is abnormally attuned to inner
conflict
and loses power dramatically if its
possessor practices any form of
self-deception
this want wood is said to be
particularly useful when it comes to
charm work
there are no known witches or wizards in
canon that use
this wand wood cedar cedar aka
cedrus is a genus of coniferous trees in
the plant family
pinnacier they are native to the
mountains of the western himalayas
and the mediterranean region ollivander
had this to say
whenever i meet one who carries a cedar
wand i find strength of character
and unusual loyalty my father gervais
ollivander
used to always say you will never fool
the cedar carrier
and i agree the cedar wand finds its
perfect home
where there is perspicacity and
perception
one known cedar one donor is none other
than professor horace slughorn
cherry now i'm sure you've heard of
cherry trees before
trees that come from the genus prunus
i'm sure you've also heard of some of
the witches and wizards
that use cherry ones but first let's
hear what ollivander has to say
this very rare wanderwood creates a wand
of strange power
most highly prized by the wizarding
students of the school
mahutukuro in japan where those who own
cherry
ones have special prestige the western
one to purchaser
should dispel from their minds any
notion that the pink blossom of the
living tree
makes for a frivolous or merely
ornamental wand
for cherrywood often makes a wand and
possesses
truly lethal power known cherry wand
owners include neville longbottom
gilderoy lockhart and albus potter
chestnut chestnuts are a group of eight
or nine species of deciduous trees and
shrubs
in the genus castaner in the beech
family
for jca they are native to temperate
regions of the northern hemisphere
the name chestnut also refers to the
edible nuts produced by these trees
ollivander had this to say this is a
most
curious multi-faceted wood which varies
greatly in its character
depending on the wand core and takes a
great deal of color from the personality
that possesses it
the wand of chestnut is attracted to
witches and wizards
who are skilled tamers of magical beasts
those who possess great gifts in
herbology and those who are natural
fliers
known chestnut one donors include peter
pettigrew
cyprus cyprus is the name applied to
many of the plants belonging to the
cypress family
most cypress species are trees while a
few are shrubs
ollivander had this to say cypress ones
are associated with nobility
the great medieval wand maker geraint
ollivander
wrote that he was always honored to
match a cyprus wand for he knew he was
meeting a witch or wizard who would die
a heroic death
fortunately in these less bloodthirsty
times the possessors of cyprus ones are
rarely called upon
to lay down their lives though doubtless
many of them would do so if required
known cyprus one donors include remus
lupin
which fits perfectly dogwood dogwood
comes from
cornice a genus of about 30 to 60
species
of woody plants in the family cornicie
which can generally be distinguished by
their blossoms
berries and distinctive bark ollivander
had this to say
dogwood is one of my own personal
favorites and i've found
that matching a dogwood wand with its
ideal owner is always entertaining
dogwood ones are quirky and to
mischievous they have playful natures
and insist upon partners
who can provide them with scope for
excitement and fun
it would be quite wrong however to
deduce from this the dogwood ones are
not capable
of serious magic when called upon to do
so one
peculiar aspect of dogwood ones however
is that they refuse to perform
non-verbal magic there are no known
witches wizards in canon that use a
dogwood wand
ebony ebony is a dense black brown
hardwood
most commonly yielded by several species
in the genus
diosperos it is finely textured and has
a mirror finish when polished
making it valuable as an ornamental wood
olivenda had this to say
this jet black wantwood has an
impressive appearance and reputation
being highly suited to all manners of
combative magic
and to transfiguration ebony is happiest
in the hand of those with the courage to
be themselves
frequently non-conformist highly
individual or comfortable with the
status of outsider
ebony one's owners have been found both
among the ranks of the order of the
phoenix
and among the death eaters there are no
known witches wizards in canon
that use an ebony wand elder you have
got to know this one elderwood which is
the rarest word of all
comes from the genus sambucus a genus of
between five and thirty species of
shrubs
or small trees in the moschitel family
ollivander had theirs to say the rarest
wanted wood of all
and reputed to be deeply unlucky the
elder wand is trickier to master
than any other it contains powerful
magic but scorns remain with any owner
who is not the superior of his or her
company
it takes a remarkable wizard to keep the
elder wand for any length of time
the old superstition wand of elder never
prosper
has its basis in this fear of the wand
but in fact
the superstition is baseless and those
foolish want makers who refuse to work
with elder
do so more because they doubt that they
will be able to sell their products
than from fear of working with this wood
known owners of ones
well one wand containing elder wood
include antioch peverell
emmerich the evil eggbert the egregious
godolo herwood barnabas cuff loxius
gregorovich grindelwald dumbledore
malfoy and harry potter
elm elms are deciduous and
semi-deciduous trees
comprising the flowering plant genus
ulmus
in the plant family el messier these
trees are spread over most of the
northern hemisphere
ollivander had this to say the truth is
that elm ones prefer owners with
presence
magical dexterity and a certain native
dignity
of all wonder words elm in my experience
produces the fewest accidents the least
foolish errors
and the most elegant charms and spells
these are sophisticated ones
capable of highly advanced magic in the
right hands
lucius malfoy inherited his own elm wand
from his father
abraxas malfoy english oak
english oak is a species of flowering
plant in the beach and oak family
for jca it is native to most of western
europe
olivenda had this to say a wand for good
times and bad
this is a friend as loyal as the wizard
who deserves it
ones of english oak demand partners of
strength
courage and fidelity less well-known is
the propensity for owners of english oak
ones
to have powerful intuition and often
an affinity with the magic of the
natural world with the creatures and
plants that are necessary to wizard kind
for both magic and pleasure known owners
of oak ones include rubius hagrid
and potentially the most powerful wizard
to have ever lived
merlin fur furs are a genus of
48 to 56 species of evergreen coniferous
trees in the family
peninsula they are found through much of
north and central america
europe asia and north africa
occurring in mountains over most of the
range ollivander had this to say of
furwood
my great-grandfather gerbelled octavius
ollivander
always called ones of this wood the
survivor's wand
because he had sold it to three wizards
who subsequently
passed through mortal peril unscathed
there is no doubt that this wood coming
as it does from the most resilient of
trees
produces ones that demand staying power
and strength of purpose in their true
owners
and that they are poor tools in the
hands of the changeable and indecisive
fur ones are particularly suited to
transfiguration
minerva mcgonagall notably used a wand
made of fur
makes sense hawthorne hawthorne is a
species a flowering plant in the rose
family
rosaceae it is native to europe north
western africa
and west asia but has also been
introduced in many other parts of the
world
interestingly ollivander and wantmaker
gragorovich
who often disagree are on the same page
about this one
grugorovich had this to say hawthorne
makes a strange
contradictory wand as full of paradoxes
as the tree that gave it birth
whose leaves and blossoms heal and yet
whose cut
branches smell of death olivander
continues
while i disagree with many of
gragorovich's conclusions
we concur about hawthorne ones which are
complex and intriguing in their natures
just like the owners who best suit them
hawthorne ones may be particularly
suited to healing magic
but they are also adept at curses and i
have
generally observed that the hawthorne
wand seems most at home
with a conflicted nature or with a witch
or wizard
passing through a period of turmoil
draco malfoy notably used a wand made of
hawthorne
hazel hazel is a genius of deciduous
trees and large shrubs
native to the temperate northern
hemisphere ollivander had this to say
a sensitive wand hazel often reflects
its owner's emotional state
and works best for a master who
understands and can manage their own
feelings
others should be very careful handling a
hazel wand if its owner has recently
lost their temper
or suffered a serious disappointment
because the wand will absorb
such energy and discharge it
unpredictably
sipple trelloni notably used wand made
of hazel
holly holly comes from the genus alexis
which is comprised of about 480 species
of flowering plants in the family
aquifoliaceae
the species are evergreen or deciduous
trees
shrubs and climbers from tropics to
temperate zones worldwide
ollivander had this to say holly is one
of the rarer kinds of want woods
traditionally considered protective it
works most happily
for those who may need help overcoming a
tendency to anger
and impetuosity at the same time holy
ones often choose owners
who are engaged in some dangerous and
often spiritual quest
harry potter the boy who lived notably
used a wand made of holly
hornbeam hornbeams are hardwood trees in
the flowering plant genus
carpenus in the birch family the 30 to
40 species
can be found across much of the
temperate regions of the northern
hemisphere
ollivander who has a hornbeam wand
himself had this to say
my own wand is made of hornbeam and so
it is with all due modesty
that i state that hornbeam selects for
its lifemate the talented witch or
wizard
with a single pure passion which some
might call obsession
though i prefer the term vision which
will almost always be realized
hornbeam ones adapt more quickly than
almost any other to their owner's style
of magic
and will become so personalized so
quickly
that other people will find them
extremely difficult to use
even for the most simple of spells two
known owners of hornbeam ones include
ollivander
as mentioned above and victor crum larch
larches are deciduous conifers from the
genus
laryx these plants can grow anywhere
from 20 to 45 meters tall
and are native to much of the cooler
temperate northern hemisphere
ollivander had this to say strong
durable and warm in color
larch has long been valued as an
attractive and powerful wonderwood
its reputation for instilling courage
and confidence in the user
has ensured the demand has always
outstripped supply
this much sought after wand is however
hard to please in the matter of ideal
owners and trickier to handle than many
imagine
i find that it always creates ones of
hidden talents and unexpected effects
which likewise describes the master who
deserves it
celestina warbeck a hogwarts graduate
and popular singer
notably used a wand made of larch laurel
laurel belongs to the genus loris which
is comprised of evergreen trees
olivand had this to say of laurel wood
it
is said that a laurel one cannot perform
a dishonorable act
although in the quest for glory a not
uncommon goal for those best suited to
these ones
i have known that laurel ones perform
powerful and sometimes
lethal magic laurel ones are sometimes
called fickle
but this is unfair the laurel wand seems
unable to tolerate laziness
in a possessor and it is in such
conditions that it is most easily and
willingly won away
otherwise it will cleave happily to its
first match forever
and indeed has the unusual and engaging
attribute of issuing a spontaneous
lightning strike if another witcher
wizard attempts to steal it
that lightning strike is quite a good
defense mechanism
i can only imagine how messy things
would have been if the same thing
occurred for the elder wand
it's worth noting that there are no
known witches and wizards in canon
that use a laurel wood wand maple
maples fall into the genus acer a family
of trees and shrubs
of which there are approximately 132
species
most of these species are native to asia
with a number
also appearing in europe northern africa
and
north america ollivander had this to say
of maple
i have often found that those chosen by
maple ones are by nature
travelers and explorers they are not
stay-at-home ones
and prefer ambition in their witch or
wizard otherwise their magic
grows heavy and lackluster fresh
challenges and regular changes i've seen
caused this wand to literally shine
burnishing itself as it grows
with its partner inability and status
there are no known canon owners of maple
ones
pear pear trees which come from the
genus pyrus
are most well known for producing a
fruit of the same name
the tree is medium-sized and native to
coastal and
mildly temperate regions of europe north
africa
and asia ollivander had this to say of
pear trees
this golden-toned wood produces ones of
splendid
magical powers which give off their best
in the hands of the warm-hearted
the generous and the wise possessors of
pair wands are
in my experience usually popular and
well respected
i do not know of a single instance where
a pair wand has been discovered
in the possession of a dark witch or
wizard there are no known canon owners
of pear ones
pine pine comes from the genus pinus of
the peninsula family there are about 115
species of pine
although different authorities accept
between 105
and 125 species olivender had this to
say
of pine the straight grained pined wand
always chooses an independent
individual master who may be perceived
as a loner
intriguing and perhaps mysterious pine
ones enjoy being used creatively
and unlike some others will adapt
unprotestingly
to new methods and spells many want
makers insist
that pint ones are able to detect and
perform best for
owners who are destined for long lives
there are
no known canon owners of pine ones
poplar poplar comes from the genus
populous
a genus of 25 to 30 species of deciduous
flowering plants in the family celecacie
native to most of the northern
hemisphere ollivander had this to say
of poplar if you seek integrity search
first among the poplars
was a great maxim of my grandfather
gerbild ollivander
and to my own experience of popular ones
and their owners
tallies exactly with this here is a wand
to rely upon
of consistency strength and uniform
power
always happiest when working with the
witch or wizard of clear
moral vision two of the ministry of
magic's
most accomplished ministers used popular
ones
eldritch diggory and evangeline
orpington
red oak red oak also known as northern
red oak
is an oak inn you guessed it the red oak
group
it is a native of north america in the
eastern and central united states
as well as southeast and south central
canada
ollivander had this to say of red oak
ones
you will often hear the ignorant say
that red oak is an infallible sign of
its owner's hot temper
in fact the true match for a red oak
wand is possessed of unusually fast
reactions
making it a perfect dueling wand less
common than english oak
i have found that its ideal master is
light of touch
quick-witted and adaptable often the
creator of distinctive
trademark spells and a good man a woman
to have beside one in a fight
there are no known canon owners of red
oak ones
redwood redwoods also known as sequoio
day
is a subfamily of coniferous trees
within the family
cupra sassier some of the largest and
tallest trees in the world are redwoods
so i'm sure we can expect great things
here ollivander had this to say
one to quality redwood is in short
supply yet
constant demand due to its reputation
for bringing
good fortune to its owner as is usually
the case with one to law
the general populace have the truth back
to front
redwood ones are not themselves lucky
but are strongly attracted
to witches and wizards who already
possess the admirable ability
to fall on their feet to make the right
choice to snatch advantage from
catastrophe
there are no known canon owners of
redwood wands
rowan rowan which comes from the genus
sorbus
are comprised of shrubs and small trees
from the rosaceae family
they are native throughout the cool
temperate regions of the northern
hemisphere
with the highest species diversity in
the mountains of the himalayas
ollivander had this to say rowanwood has
always been
much favored for once because it is
reputed to be more protective
than any other and in my experience
renders all manner of defensive charms
especially strong and difficult to break
it is commonly stated
that no dark witch or wizard ever owned
a rowan wand
and i cannot recall a single instance
where one of my own
rowan ones has gone on to do evil in the
world
ollivander also once noted that wizards
chosen by rowan ones
tend to be compassible with those chosen
by elder ones
interesting there are also no known
canon owners of rowan
ones silver lime the unusual named
silver lime is a species of flowering
plant in the family
malvasier native to southeastern europe
and southwestern asia ollivander had
this to say
this unusual and highly attractive wand
wood was greatly in vogue in the 19th
century
demand outstripped supply and
unscrupulous want makers
dyed substandard ones in an effort to
fool purchasers into believing
that they had purchased silver lime the
reasons for these ones desirability
lay not only in their unusually handsome
appearance but also because they had a
reputation
for performing best for sears and those
skilled in legitimacy
there are no known canon owners of
silverline ones
spruce a spruce is a tree of the genus
pasilla which is comprised of about 35
species of coniferous evergreen trees
in the family pinnace found in the
northern
temperate and boreal regions of the
earth ollivander had this to say
of spruce ones unskilled want makers
call spruce a difficult wood but in
doing so
they revealed their own ineptitude it is
quite true that it requires particular
deafness to work with spruce which
produces ones that are ill-matched
with cautious or nervous natures and
become positively dangerous
in fumbling fingers the spruce wand
requires a firm hand
because it often appears to have its own
ideas about what magic
it ought to be called upon to produce
however when a spruce wand meets its
match
which in my experience is a bold spell
caster with a good sense of humor
it becomes a superb helper intensely
loyal to their owners
and capable of producing particularly
flamboyant
and dramatic effects there are no known
canon owners of spruce ones the sycamore
the sycamore is a name which has
actually been applied to several types
of trees
with somewhat similar leaf forms in
harry potter
sycamore trees can be found in the
forest of dean as well as the forbidden
forest
ollivander had this to say of sycamores
the sycamore makes a questing wand
eager for new experience and losing
brilliance if engaged in mundane
activities
it is a quirk of these handsome ones
that they may combust if allowed to
become
bored and many witches and wizards
settling down into middle age
are disconcerted to find their trusty
wand bursting into flame in their hand
as they ask it one more time to fetch
their slippers
as may be deduced the sycamores ideal
owner
is curious vital and adventurous
there are no known canon owners of
sycamore ones
vine vines refer to any plant with a
growth habit of trailing or
scandant that is to say climbing stems
or runners
however in some parts of the world the
british isles included
the term vine is applied exclusively to
grapevines
olivander had this to say of vines vine
ones are among the less common types
and i've been intrigued to notice that
their owners are nearly always those
witches and wizards who seek a greater
purpose
who have a vision beyond the ordinary
and who frequently astound those who
think
they know them best vine ones seem
strongly attracted by personalities
with hidden depths and i found them more
sensitive than any other
when it comes to instantly detecting a
prospective match
hermione granger notably possessed a ten
and three-quarter inch wand
made with vine walnut walnut trees are a
large
deciduous tree species from the genus
jugulans
that produce edible walnuts olivander
had this to say
of walnuts highly intelligent witches
and wizards ought to be offered a walnut
wand for trial first
because in nine cases out of ten the two
will find in each other
their ideal mate walnut ones are often
found in the hands of magical innovators
and
inventors this is a handsome wood
possessed of unusual versatility
and adaptability bellatrix lestrange
notably possessed a 12 and three-quarter
inch wand
made with walnut willow willows
also called sallows form the genus salix
which is comprised of around 400 species
of deciduous trees and shrubs that can
be found primarily on
moist soils in cold and temperate
regions of the northern hemisphere
ollivander had this to say of willows
willow is an uncommon wonder wood with
healing power
and i've noted that the ideal owner for
a willow wand
often has some usually unwarranted
insecurity
however well they may try and hide it
while many confident customers insist on
trying a willow wand
attracted by their handsome appearance
and well-founded reputation
for enabling advanced non-verbal magic
my
willow ones have consistently selected
those of greatest potential
rather than those who feel they have
little to learn
ron weasley's second wand was notably
made of willow
you and last of all we have you
you refers to various coniferous trees
and shrubs in the genus
taxes in harry potter you trees can be
found in the forbidden forest
ollivander had this to say of you you
ones are among the rarer kinds
and their ideal matches are likewise
unusual and occasionally
notorious the wonder view is reputed to
endow its possessor
with the power of life and death which
might of course
be said of all ones and yet you retains
a particularly dark and fearsome
reputation
in the spheres of dueling and all curses
tom riddle's first wand was made of you
as was
ginny weasley's and that's it for this
video i hope you guys learned something
about
ones if you've taken the wand quiz
before then comment your wonder wood
down below
if you haven't taken it you should but
still leave a comment with your favorite
wonder wood until next time you're a
wizard oury
you